لذا قامت القوات الخاصة الإسرائيلية
بغارة هذا الأسبوع على مستشفى الضفة الغربية
بالطبع لقد رأيتم
اللقطات وسأقوم بتشغيلها مرة أخرى
هنا وهم متنكرون في زي مدنيين
وطاقم طبي، حتى أن أحدهم لديه
أي نوع من  مثل سرير طفل
أه دخلوا أه قتل ثلاثة فلسطينيين
تزعم إسرائيل أه كانوا
إرهابيين أه هذا كان الهدف من
الغارة الآن المستشفى يقول أن
أحد الرجال الذين قُتلوا كان يتلقى
إصابات أه يتلقى العلاج من
الإصابات  الذي عانى منه في
هجوم صاروخي وهناك في الواقع لقطات
له أه في سريره بالمستشفى من الواضح أنه
قبل هذا أه مع عائلته عندما
ترى هذه الصور هل أنت مرتاح
لهذا النوع من التكتيكات المتمثلة في
ارتداء ملابس مدنية والذهاب إلى
المستشفى ل  اقتل الإرهابيين جيدًا
السؤال الحقيقي هو هل أنا مرتاح
لاستخدام الإرهابيين المستشفيات كملاذ آمن لهم أه
لأننا نحارب
الإرهابيين الذين تعلمون أنه ليس لديهم
خطوط حمراء أه لا أه أه يلتزمون بأي قانون
ونحن متمسكون ب  ازدواجية
المعايير المزدوجة CU حماس تفعل ما
تريد
وتستخدم الأطفال والعائلات
كدرع بشري وبعد ذلك عندما يتعين علينا الذهاب
لاستهداف هؤلاء الكامنيك الذين يستخدمون
المستشفى كملجأ، فإننا
متهمون بذلك ولكن هذا قليل
مختلف بعض الشيء على الأقل في هذه الحالة،
صحيح إذا كان هذا الرجل يرقد بالفعل في
سرير المستشفى مصابًا ولم يكن يستخدمه
كملجأ، فقد كان يعالج من
إصابات على حد علمي،
فنحن نتحدث عن إرهابيين
استخدموا المستشفى بالفعل  كلاجئين ليس لأنهم
كانوا يتعالجون أه علينا أن
ننظر إلى كل أه حادث ولكن على العموم ما
رأيناه في غزة وفي
الضفة الغربية أه بأعداد كبيرة جدا أه
حماس تستخدم المستشفيات المدارس
رياض الأطفال كملجأ هذا هو الحقيقي
لا توجد مشكلة واحدة من بين ألف حالة
حيث نحاول
إخراجهم من المكان الذي يختبئون فيه،
أفهم تمامًا ما تقوله
وأعتقد أن كل من يشاهده يفهمه
أيضًا ولكني أريد فقط المضي قدمًا في
ذلك  نقطة واحدة لأنه يجب أن
أقول في الواقع إنها مثيرة للإعجاب جدًا
أه العملية آه إرسال جنود
عليهم
أه التنكر داخل الإرهابيين
واختطاف الإرهابيين هذا
ما سنفعله وعلينا أن ندافع عن
رؤية المزيد من ذلك  سنرى أي
شيء ضروري، أشخاص في
المستشفى، يمكن أن يكون المستشفى من النساء والأطفال،
الأشخاص الذين لديهم أطفال، هذا الرجل حتى لو لكننا
لا نستهدفهم، نحن لا نستهدفهم،
نحن لا نستهدفهم، لم
نتعمد أبدًا استهداف النساء والأطفال
لكن ذلك الرجل
أصيب أيضًا، كما تعلم إذا كان أسامة بن لادن
في المستشفى وكان إبهامه
مصابًا
أه، فهل ستدخل وتقتله،
فالإجابة هي نعم حسنًا، لذا تقول وكالة غوث الأمم المتحدة
في غزة إنه سيتعين عليها ذلك
تعليق أعمالها الإغاثية في
جميع أنحاء الشرق الأوسط بأكمله لأن ما أكثر
من 20 حكومة الآن أوقفت
تمويل أونرا أه بعد
المخابرات الإسرائيلية التي قدمتموها أه
معلومات اطلعت عليها هذه
الحكومات أن 13 من أكثر من
13 ألف موظف في غزة أه  من الأونرا
شاركوا في هجمات 7 أكتوبر الآن
يقول رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو أنه
يجب القضاء على الأونرا من الواضح أنها
تقدم أه إنها تقوم بعمل جيد في
المنطقة بطرق أخرى هل تعتقد أنه
يجب القضاء عليها بالكامل أعتقد
أنه يجب أه حلها
لسببين الأول هو السبب التكتيكي الذي
بالفعل أه العشرات من أه العاملين فيها هم
إرهابيون الذين دخل بعضهم
وقتلوا إسرائيليين مقتولين
وهو ال وكما تعلم
شارك في هذه المذبحة ولكن
هناك شيء أكبر من ذلك نعم
هذا  الوكالة بدلاً من حل
مشكلة اللاجئين، فإنها تستوعب
مشكلة اللاجئين، ترى أن هؤلاء اللاجئين
هم أحفاد أحفاد اللاجئين، إنها
الحالة الوحيدة في العالم التي يتم فيها
توريث وضع اللاجئ من
جيل إلى آخر، لذا بدلاً من
حلها، يقومون بتخليدها، كما تعلمون
حرب الاستقلال هؤلاء أه
الفلسطينيين أصبحوا لاجئين لكن هناك
أيضا 700 ألف يهودي أصبحوا
لاجئين طردوا من الدول العربية
مثل المغرب ومصر وغيرها
ولم يصبحوا لاجئين لقد
استوعبناهم والآن أصبحوا
إسرائيليين بالكامل لذلك هناك  الهدف هو إبقاء
الفلسطينيين في بؤس وأعتقد أن unra
هو جزء من المشكلة وليس جزءًا من
الحل، لذا فأنا أفهم ذلك ولكني
أردت تقديم بعض
الأمثلة المحددة لأنه إذا كنت تريد
القضاء عليه، فما الذي يحل محل الخير
الذي يفعله  هل أعني أننا كنا
نبحث للتو عن بعض الأرقام 140
عيادة رعاية صحية أولية 7 ملايين شخص
يحصلون على زيارات صحية سنوية من
مرافق غير مُدارة 200 مدرسة تعمل
50000 طالب متعلم الآن يمكنك
المراوغة بالأرقام هنا وهناك
ولكن هناك أشياء مهمة
حسنًا، يمكنك القضاء عليها والتي تختفي
أيضًا، لذا من الواضح أنه يتعين علينا
استمرار هذه الخدمات ويجب أن تكون هناك
فترة انتقالية، نحن لا نتحدث
عن قطعها كما تعلمون يومًا بعد
يوم وتوفير هؤلاء
الفلسطينيين وإبقائهم بدون حلول ولكننا
يجب أن ننظر إلى منظمة
أصبحت فاسدة للغاية لدرجة أن بعض
موظفيها ذهبوا وقتلوا
وذبحوا اليهود، وهذه هي المشكلة
في مهمتها ذاتها، لذا ستكون هناك
فترة انتقالية ولكن يتعين علينا
إصلاحها